y así es los líderes europeos se reúnen
en un momento Poco después de que el
presidente de chinos haya visitado
Moscú los líderes europeos en abordado
esta ayuda a Ucrania como comentabais En
qué inevitablemente se produce también
sobre estas conversaciones de una futura
paz en el conflicto con este plan de paz
que ha presentado Pekín a
Moscú pero los líderes europeos han
dejado Claro que cualquier intento de
que china sea mediadora de este de esta
posible Paz pasa inevitablemente porque
china hable con Ucrania de hecho se
espera que Próximamente
hable con el presidente ucraniano
voleimir zelemski precisamente el primer
líder europeo que viajará a China será
el presidente del gobierno español Pedro
Sánchez la semana que vienen que
abordará las relaciones comerciales
entre ambos países pero que se espera
también que pueda escuchar también este
plan de paz por parte de China los
líderes como comentabas han hablado
también con el
en que ha pedido más armas más munición
y más ayuda también con aviones porque
si no la guerra se va a prolongar aún
más los líderes han escuchado estas
palabras de Vladimir zelenski y acto
seguido han aprobado este nuevo envío de
nuevas municiones para los próximos 12
meses los líderes han abordado también
la situación económica en concreto la
respuesta que se ha dado la ley de
reducción de la inflación de Estados
Unidos que la Unión Europea considera
muy discriminatoria pero también las
relaciones comerciales Especialmente con
países de América Latina para la
comisión europea es de especial
importancia las relaciones con chile
pero también con el bloque de mercosur
especialmente porque quieren dejar de
depender menos de Rusia menos de china
en cuestión de tierras raras y por ello
creen que es muy importante Ahora más
que nunca mantener más relaciones con
América Latina porque es un socio mucho
más fiable